hallo herzlich willkommen zur welt ich
habe euch erzählt dass ich auf die esm
als auch die internationale
süßwarenmesse nach köln gehen und da bin
ich jetzt gerade heute ist schon der
dritte tag und ich habe mir das jetzt
auch bisher ausgehoben und möchte ich
jetzt heute einfach mal zeigen was ihr
denn so alles los ist und was es hier
gibt also die gsm dass ich wirklich
weltweit die größte süßwarenmesse und
ich war letztes jahr auch schon hier und
zwar auch genau an diesem stand ich bin
nämlich immer mit der firma deco pack
ihr seht ihr auch da er kennt die firma
auch schon aus meinen videos die stelle
hier die ganzen torten dekoration her
also von dornier schokolade und die
ganzen zucker teure lebensmittel
verpackt so weiter und die habe ich ja
kennengelernt weil die bei uns aus der
region kommen als aus reichertshausen
das ist bei sinsheim und ist ganz bei
uns in der nähe und ich habe die letzten
tage hier bisschen modelliert und
dekoriert also letzte habe ich sogar
geschafft ich glaube 12 torten habe ich
letztes jahr dekoriert kann ich euch ja
auch ein paar bilder mal zeigen also
unter anderem habe ich da eine bienen
torte modelliert und noch ganz viele
andere torten und dieses jahr habe ich
nicht so ganz viele torten geschafft das
lag unter anderem daran dass die ela mit
dabei ist dann ab und zu mal stellen
muss und dass die samira mit dabei war
oder ist
und zwar hat es mir auch ein paar torten
dekoriert und irgendwie kam ich mir
mittlerweile vor mir als assistentin
also eigentlich viel mehr dekoriert als
ich und ich war dann halt so ein
bisschen
die hilfsarbeiterin neben dran und ich
hab hier die letzten tage drei torten
modelliert und zwar habe ich einfach den
besuchern gezeigt wie man eben mit den
produkten umgeht und die besucher das
sind jetzt keine endverbraucher also
hier kann ich jede auf die messe kommen
sondern das sind alles fachbesucher das
heißt hier kommen dann leute her die zum
beispiel
im supermarkt sind also rewe edeka
globus alle einkäufer oder es kommen
leute mit einem online-shop oder eben
andere fachhändler und der eintritt hier
ist auch relativ teuer also das machen
die auch absichtlich so ich glaube
christi tat ist etwa 50 euro
und zwar machen es eben auch so weil man
eben keinen keinen normalen besucher
möchte denn hier gibt es auch nichts zu
kaufen also man kann ewig nix kaufen
informiert sich hier einfach über die
neuheiten und ich habe jetzt hier auch
ein paar neuheiten vorgestellt und ich
würde es mir sagen ich nehme euch kurz
mit nach hinten zeigt ich erstmal den
neuheiten bei deko faktisch richtig
genial finde weil ich nämlich auch mit
deko park immer mitarbeiten darf also
ich kann zum beispiel sagen ich hätte
gerne dieses oder jenes produkt und dann
entwickeln wir das einfach zusammen oder
die firma schlägt mir produkte vor und
ich teste sie und wenn sie gut sind dann
wird es eben entwickeln jetzt kommt er
einfach mal mit nach hinten und ich
zeige euch ein paar sachen also was ich
euch zuallererst sagen muss die firma
hatte er vor hat die farbe gelb und so
ein bisschen orange bremse das geändert
auf pink sich ja auch meine farbe hallo
sophie schöner warmer hier so pink
türkis ist echt richtig schön und das
hat mich viele auch in meinen letzten
videos gefragt die haben dann gefragt
wieso benutzer nicht mehr die produkte
von de bug
also ich bin aber auch wir haben jetzt
eine andere verpackung habe ich nur
vergessen zu erwähnen
also hier zum beispiel ist der ganze
rolle von land da gibt zwischen dieser
fondant decke die noch im alten design
das wird aber auch noch geändert
hier gibt's sondern stoppte schnell
genau ein kilo
dann haben wir hier diese verschiedenen
geschmacksrichtung und das ist jetzt
neuheiten mit dabei zum beispiel hier
erdbeere und zwar rasch dass das einzige
produkt wirklich weltweit was richtige
erdbeeren mit in dem vom land hat also
ein richtiges etwa püree mit drin
auf meiner torte hier sieht man zb auf
dieses erdbeer markt also diese kleine
pünktchen und die bekommt man auch nicht
weg und das ist auch gut so denn da ist
wirklich das produkt mit dabei hier hat
man das ganze noch in bananen das macht
auch richtig gut schmeckt halt setzte
nach künstlicher banane sondern es ist
wirklich echte banane mit drin
dann haben wir hier den schock sondern
dann habe ich schon öfter benutzt hier
vanille und was es hier auch neu ist das
ist silber und gold und zwar hat man da
drin einer geöffneten packung
hat man da zum beispiel in fondant und
noch ein päckchen pulver farbe und zwar
ist es so eine grundfarbe hier so eine
orange ton und entdeckt man die torte
mit einem kann dann später das gold
kunde einfach drüber pudern also das
ganz gut weil es gibt ja keinen fertigen
goldenen von land das geht ja gar nicht
so und die sachen sind auch alle im
supermarkt erhältlich ja da oben ist
auch noch wundern
und dann gehen wir kurz darüber da mal
hier zum beispiel da gibt es auch ganz
viele neue sachen also hier die modelle
jetta diese kinder schon bearbeitete
auch damit dann gibt's hier zum beispiel
das farbtupfer also es gibt dann auch in
der kleinen döschen und es ist eben auch
das gleiche farbpulver wie in dem von
hand mit drin nur eben dass man diese
verschließbare dose hat und es eben gut
funktionieren kann
erzieher dass ich mein absolutes
highlight also mein favourit und zwar
sind es ist es der zuckerstreuer dekor
aber da schallt frucht mit drin und es
schmeckt hat richtig gut das kann mal
den benutzten um muffins und cupcakes
oder so oder so cage zu dekorieren und
es schmeckt dann halt echt gut es gibt
hier in
bald wäre zitrone erdbeere und orange
und tutti frutti da stand alles mit
dabei sie hat echt schöne frischen
farben und auch der geschmack rechte tut
und hier eines drunter da hat dann
dieser flakes und zwar benutzt man das
auch net findet ihr alles für die
dekoration
jetzt kann ich so rausnehmen ich hätte
also kleine flocken
das team hat auch echt schön aus und
dann gibt es noch den anderen zucker de
kort des kennt ihr jetzt auch schon von
mir aber da gibt's dann auch ein paar
neue sachen als ich hier blume mit
tattoo
hier sind noch herzchen mit tattoo die
zucker augen die finde ich ja immer
super hier seine crew werde diesen von
süß und lustig kussmund das hat samira
auf ihrer karte benutzt und ich habe das
auch bei meiner valentinstag scorte
genutzt hier die farbstifte die so
genial sind also mit dicker und dünner
seite und da oben die essbaren diamanten
die sind einmal in durchsichtig und
einmal in rosa die admira auf genutzt
und da oben den habt jetzt bei mir auch
schon im gebrauchen sehen die sich der
essbare kleber der ist hier in seiner
truppe drin und man kann den eben gut
funktionieren also man kann den eben
punktuell auftragen oder man keinen auch
großflächig auftragen
er hat zum beispiel das cape zubehör
also diese
cake poker so hat die mal eben schmelzen
kann einmal in weiß und rosa hier die
sticks dazu und hier oben drüber haben
wir so diese saisonalen deko artikel wie
zb geister da oben sind lebkuchen männer
oder teddybärchen mit seinem genie
bonbon da drin
hier sind kleine monster ich finde ich
so süß oder eulen ich bin in euren fans
also ich hab echt ganz schöne sachen
hier noch handtaschen und schuhe geister
da sind noch so prinzessin kronen
teddybär hier noch besser auch ganz gut
vor halloween und für den hof
was sie dort ganz neu ist hier diese
elsa zucker dekore die maxime ihrer
natürlich ganz gerne und wir müssen auch
dem nächsten paar älter und olaf capex
damit verzieren habe hier schon
versprochen
und die finde ich auch ganz hübsch
jetzt hat
nochmals ein paar produkte gesehen und
neben mir steht ist die karte rüdiger
ist einer der inhaber von de bug
würdiger ganz ehrlich was hast du denn
gedacht als du mich unterm rad das erste
mal ehrlich sein über holz bekommen
können
wir stehen seit über drei jahren zum
beispiel neue produkte und dann gibt es
für uns und wir testen die und dann
kriegt er halt ein echtes feedback von
uns mehr positiv oder negativ
bisher war immer positiv aber wenn mal
was kritisches wort und wird geändert es
sich ja immer gut
und ja es wege ist denn die produkte
dann halt auch brot gutes beispiel
damals mit lebensmittelfarben dazu nicht
abzutun
das hatte man normalerweise weil die
lebensmittelfarbe immer abzuhalten und
der rüdiger verkauft er also deko backt
wird ja auch im supermarkt angeboten und
da gab es da keine problematik mit den
farben und die umstellung ist ziemlich
schwierig weil die art zu fahren sind
sei leicht stark und kräftig und ohne
abo waren die erst mal nicht so toll
aber mittlerweile ich quäle ich nicht
weiter und wir gehen jetzt weiter und
erkundet noch den rest der messe graz wo
seid ihr
dankeschön
also samira ist es natürlich jetzt echt
genial sind sie hat versprochen weil sie
nicht den kindergarten konnte sie zwei
tage dass er eben was für ihre
kindergartenfreunde mitnimmt macht
erhalte kinderwagen volle container
weiter
und hier auf der messe gibt es auch echt
viele marken die man schon kennt von der
werbung zum beispiel trolley jetzt
können kinder aus der werbung ausgibt
dann auch viele marken die man es kennt
und die dann einfach versuchen in
supermärkte oder in online-shops
reinzukommen
und da zeigen wir euch ganz ganz viele
um ein stopp da gehen wir noch kurz rein
kommen sie mal vorbei gelaufen
das ist halt das geniale auf der messe
mit kind aber gucken dass ich immer den
ganzen kinderwagen und dieser mirage
übrigens auch das einzige kind auf der
messe ist nämlich extra ein ausweis
bekommen als künstlerin
denn ansonsten dürfen kinder hier ganz
auf die messe eine kindersachen bis auf
der messe
solche sachen vertreiben wir in
deutschland wo wir hoffen von den
ausländischen herstellern ein und
vertreiben sie allein in deutschland
machen an den deutschen handel und ganz
erfolgreich gerade auch die schweizer
artikel besondere qualität der schweiz
frankreich den usa und in sofern ist
dass einige nationen lieblingsschokolade
daher machen wir eben eine torte damit
okay
samira wartet noch auf den com berlin
der verdacht ich mal die zeit und fragt
dich besonders lesefreundlich unbedingt
dieses mikrowellen popcorn kaufen was
macht es so besonders
es gibt ja auch andere posten sollte
aber das thema genau anschaut sieht es
wunderschön aus es hat kinoqualität
und es sind zwei bis drei minuten fertig
wir zu hause wenn die zu hause im
filmhaus also kann es ja auch mal
probieren hast du schon probiert gerne
mit euch neben ja nochmal besser also
das jetzt ist süße wenn man möchte
was habt ihr dann noch
geschmacksrichtungen
ok dann warten wir kurze drei minuten
und ich es hier sondern so warm ist
sozusagen zwar die letzten drei tage
zwei tage wissen verschluckt und habe
nichts gerochen und nichts schmecken
können und hat dann halt auch nichts
gegessen und jetzt am dritten tag kann
das ausnutzen und kann alles nachholen
deswegen wundert euch das hier zu viel
süßes essen aber ich habe die letzten
tage wirklich nicht viel
hab ich doch auch mein eigenes
tenniswelt süßigkeit und dsm werden die
neuheiten präsentieren also so
innovative produkte und das gehört eben
auch mit dazu also das ist so ein 3d
drucker es tut der gratis forsch uns mal
trug der die süßigkeit und zwar ist
dieses produkt rein auf pflanzlicher
basis also die haben da die extrakte aus
den pflanzen und jetzt drücken die da
ebenso 3d motive
hier geht's zum beispiel die spinne oder
oktopus hier auch immer der fertige
frosch und heute hat die firma hat jetzt
sogar den preis gewonnen
den ersten platz der top innovation auf
der erde
da kriegst das papier gestern
tags drauf schreiben
ok dazu studier 1 aus zu mir sind jetzt
hier bei der firma küche kennt ihr auch
meinen videos
ich benutze immer das sommerbad wonach
dem alle fragt dass ich eben von der
firma küchen immobilienunternehmen da
waren wir auch schon in günzburg und ich
dachte sich jemand über die gibt's seit
über 150 jahren
dieses papier was drauf schreiben mit
einer katze
er hat sogar tag und gehalt
wie sagt man
sie sind mit ihrer tochter da was die
ganzen tag mit auf der messe
genau vom aufbau bis heute in vielen
unternehmen und dann müsst ihr auch mal
reinschnuppern
ja wir waren ja auch schon in günzburg
und zwar butter grad erstes papier
gemacht und die ganze stadt richtete
danach erdbeere angefahren gekommen und
aufgestiegen comics offenes papier
ich nehme das
wer selbst auch kennengelernt hier
kannst du dir mal so die neuheiten
zeigen was hat ihr neues dieses jahr die
neuheiten wird da muss ich ganz kurz
auch die deko
das sind eben einfach die moschee also
platten kann man anruft oder sonstwo
draufpacken
ja genau genau vielleicht schickt man
sich dann nicht mal mehr nur durch worte
die nachrichten sondern einfach finden
und dann ja schon weg oder haben die
kletterspinne gibt auch in drei
verschiedenen farben
kohlblätter splitter genau die clips
sind einfach kann man auch auf mehreren
aufnahmen auf alles packen und
dollar
es ist gerade im frühling genau kann man
schön kuchen platzieren oder muffins
cupcakes sind die aus esspapier
muss man da irgendwas verachten auf
sahne oder so
ich glaube nicht ja kurz vorm servieren
wahrscheinlich
war echt cool guck mal im schießen
loki
glitzer papier
ja man kann die team ganz lieb fragen ob
du das bekommst
wir haben ja was sagst du dazu
hier war
cg
hallo
also man sieht es gibt ja auch gesunde
snacks auf der esl ganz ohne zucker und
ich probiere das echte heime aus
das war jetzt echt drei richtig
anstrengende tage und ich mache jetzt im
abschluss an beim eigentlich beim
lieblings standen sich sagen denn auf
der süßigkeiten messe auf das ist
vanessa gibt es nicht nur süßes und
ungesundes sondern auch gesunde und
jetzt bin ich hier und zwar nicht den
stand gestern entdeckt hier geht's
gesunde snacks oder bei den helden gibt
es snacks arbeiten viel mit vollkorn
mailen und mit müssen und ich glaube das
outfit ist auch für die kinder passend
ich finds auch super also da ist sind
die ganzen produkte ich habe gestern zum
beispiel schon probiert also ich meine
ich habe hier auch immer mal zwischen
sex gebraucht und habe ich hier diese
frucht regel probiert da ist die banane
mandl
hier ist apfel wahllos und dass er auch
wirklich nur apfel walnuss drin oder nur
bananen mandel und ohne zucker stimmt ja
genau wie süßen nur wieder einfach zu
ja das ist echt genial vor allem wenn
man das mal den kindern mitgeben möchte
oder genau also als pausensnack super
geeignet weil es einfach auch sättigt
und trotzdem kein zucker enthalten ist
echt super also geradezu als normal als
lehrerin kennt empfehlen
wittlich als wir gesagt hast das ist
eben auch für die schule gut geht bin
ich nämlich auch samira probieren wir
also das habe ich gestern noch nicht
probiert
guck mal als gedacht
die beiden herrschaften in der mitte
eben der würfel mit kokos und lecker ich
probiere kokos
probieren kann sie bestimmt auch mit
milch essen
also wir packen hier noch ein bisserl
was ein
und ja das war jetzt echt drei tolle
tage auf der wir haben echt nur ganz
wenig gesehen ich konnte auch noch ganz
wenig zeigen und zwar bin ich jetzt hier
in der in halle im oberen stockwerk
jetzt noch ein unteres stockwerk und da
hab ich noch fünf andere halten und es
ist wirklich unmöglich die hallen alle
also alle stände überhaupt an einem tag
zu sehen geht gar nicht ich bezweifle
sogar dass man überhaupt an allen tagen
alle stände sehen kann
es ist wirklich riesengroß hier in
dieser halle habe ich euch auch nur in
ganz kleinen auszug gezeigt und es gibt
wirklich noch ganz viel mehr und ich
hoffe dass euch das video gefallen hat
wenn ihr gerne so messe videos mal sehen
wollt dann schreibt mir einfach ich bin
auf jeden fall nächstes jahr bestimmt
wieder mit dabei auf der süßwarenmesse
und erfreue ich mich schon auf die neuen
innovationen und guckt einfach mal was
es nächstes jahr hier so alles gibt
zusammenarbeit ist dann gehen wir jetzt
einfach mal ich glaube das ist genug für
den kindergarten eingepackt oder hier
kann es gern ein bisschen mehr mitnehmen
das ist nämlich gesund super
da freuen sich deine freunde genau über
die schulter hängen
super dieser klasse
und das ist herr rüdiger das ist der
inhaber der firma und ich war letztes
jahr auch schon vorher vielleicht magst
du bist was du zu sagen
ganz ganz toll in form gemacht und sehr
freundschaftlich zwischen uns außerdem
hob diesen nächsten 20 jahren noch hier
ist das war mit cd moratti
sein